[Music]
lincoln nebraska dylan is up hi
dylan what's up hi um
i am so excited to talk to you you too
what's up how can we help
um i am calling because i'm currently in
baby step
two with my husband and uh
we originally started at 25 000 and
we're down to about 16 000.
good and um my parents are going through
a really bad divorce
and my 16 year old little brother
would like to move in with me and my
husband um
we're kind of at odds about it because
i want to let him move in um but my
husband
wants to just stay so intense and he's
concerned it will be
too much of an added expense if we let
him move in
hmm are you do you live near
where he lives now no
they live about uh 45 minutes away from
us
so i guess not too bad but so i guess he
would stay in his same school and
community as a car
uh no he would transfer to school here
in my town
uh he lives in oahu it's about 45
minutes from here
and what is the financial condition of
your parents
very poor um they've filed bankruptcy
and uh they are still even after the
bankruptcy
about 25 000 in debt what's your
household income
uh 65 000.
what costs are associated with bringing
him in food
um food he would we would have to help
him get a car
because he doesn't have one and with
daycare with my son
it would conflict with school scheduling
bus doesn't run in front of your house
what'd you tell sorry does the bus not
run for the school in front of your
house
uh no it does not
but he he could he could walk for a
while um it would just be hard in the
winter and
really cold probably how far away is it
about a mile and a half hm that's not
bad it's a nice little hike
uphill both ways in the snow right um
he could tell his grandkids about it
someday uh
it sounds like things are pretty
miserable for him i want to help him
yeah me too um
so is he miserable enough to
uh take on some other forms of misery in
order to get out of there like for
instance when he moves in with you he
starts
he starts a job immediately and uh he
saves up right quick and
uh gets him a thousand dollar car and he
pays for it yeah he said
he would be willing to work i i'm just
concerned it would affect his grades
i'm concerned that he's living in a
cesspool and he needs to get out
i'm not concerned about his grades
yes that's a good point he needs to work
if i'm your husband and you came to me
and said look he'll take a job and he'll
work this many hours and make this much
money
um he'll pay us 50 bucks a month for
food and he'll save up
everything else and be on a budget the
way we teach him in order to save up and
pay
cash for for a thousand dollar car that
we're going to help him get
we could be saving his life please let's
do this for my
brother i think that's a reasonable
thing
but if your little brother wants to move
in there and sit on the couch and eat
doritos all
afternoon and suck and play video games
and sit on his butt
and then gripe because he hadn't got a
car that you gave him that he's entitled
to because he breathes air
this is a different animal you following
me
yes so i'm just if he is as desperate to
get out of that mess
as it sounds like he is then he's
desperate enough to do some crap when he
hits
the road over at your house and gets get
his life straightened out i'm sorry for
him it's a tough road he's it's a
situation he's in
his parents are both completely
unplugged um
they basically emotionally have
abandoned him financially you've
abandoned him and he's 16 years old
that's tough
i'm sorry it's heartbreaking but if i'm
your husband your husband
he doesn't want to take a project on
yeah he wants to bring and bring in
someone that he can be a blessing to
if i'm your husband that's what i would
be sitting on and
so i think you can lay out some
guidelines and and then talk to your
little brother and say
these are our conditions if you will
meet those you're welcome
and of course when you live under my
roof you live by my rules too
okay which means you're not coming home
drunk at 16 years old you're not doing
dope at 16 years old you're not doing
you know
just fill in the blank right on sunday
we go to church so this is what we do at
our house okay
if you live in my house you do what we
do at my house you don't want to live
there it's okay you don't like that
that's okay live somewhere else
but when you're under my roof this is
how it works
that's kind of old school have them open
like should we just have them a basic
savings account for the car yeah just
help him
i don't care if he puts it in a fruit
jar i just want him to work i just want
him to work
like 60 hours a week and go get him a
thousand dollars right quick
okay sounds good just bust i mean i just
want him bust his butt man
i want he's got a lot of emotion he can
burn off a bunch of it working
yeah i agree i think that he's
definitely willing to
do what it takes i think it's more i
just had revelations about
forcing him to work so much i don't i
don't have any reservations about it at
all it'd be the best thing ever happened
to him
okay he won't die from it when you're
working really really hard
right before you die you pass out so you
have to worry about work killing you it
won't kill you
so it's okay you're gonna be all right
it's gonna be the best thing ever
happened to him you're giving him a safe
emotional environment to live in
someone that loves him and actually
cares about his well-being you're a good
person
you're a good sister well done now just
put some guidelines on it so your
husband feels like he's participating in
a
process that's helpful and not enabling
a bunch of crap